when the pandemic ends
should you get new friends according to
a piece in the new york times
otherwise known as communists
[Laughter]
returning to our normal way of life
offers the perfect opportunity to ditch
your loser friends
especially if it's a friend who reads
the new york times i added that
writer kate murphy points out that we
become more like the people we surround
ourselves with
quote indeed depressed friends make it
more likely you'll be depressed
obese friends make it more likely you'll
be obese and friends who smoke and drink
a lot make it more likely you'll do the
same in other words
choose your friends by what they can do
for you
using people is the new friendship
conversely having supportive
hard-working friends will not only
make you more hard-working but it can
also improve the number of health
markers like immunity function and blood
pressure
so that settles it smoking and drinking
friends it is
during the height of the pandemic many
of us saw our social networks shrink
like george costanza stepping out of an
unheated swimming pool
now as the country reopens social
sciences say a more cultivated approach
to your post pandemic friends scape
can make you a better person so is it
selfish to cut out unhealthy people in
your life
well i already refused to hang out with
cat and her sister amazing you aren't
bruised more cat with the amount of
falling
oh yeah it is amazing
so why are you bringing my sister into
this oh yeah
i got your husband your sister you wait
but you don't like
don't you need a few quote
bad influences in your life i ask you as
i'm the good influence in your life
and you're the bad influence in mine so
so
uh it's like for example i i feel like
you got to have a span you could
you should have somebody that represents
everything
yes i agree and i think the main
determinant is if someone is
on your side or not you know it because
i've dropped friends in the pandemic
because i was like oh my anxiety's
dropped then i realized it's because i
had been having so much anxiety this
person was going to be mean to me
bad news people it's true it's like if
you have supernatural
i think the thing if you have super
negative people it's not good you have
to
and it doesn't matter what their weight
is right and it even doesn't matter if
they're depressed because you can medi
you can medicate that
it's just people that are a negative
drain on your life and you should be the
plus not the minus
to quote a book that somebody wrote that
was a new york times bestseller
plus lisa um is this how you pick your
friends if they're fat
or if they're depressed cat is that why
you stopped texting me back
i think i was there the night in the
video earlier yeah that was lisa but see
i i don't
know but you want them all though right
so like like if you you want a depressed
friend if you're having a bad day you
need someone to commiserate with
you need a fat friend if you want to go
out and you want to eat pizza
you want a drinking buddy if you have
you know or if you if you need to be in
a great
food you hang out with your friends all
your buddies are drinking buddies
jack daniels jim beam jose crain jose
cuervo
oh i'm a mexican friend now no but you
can have them all for like different
you know different stuff yeah i know i
think we have a wide variety
i think i have a picture of one of your
uh days out with a friend look at this
oh i'm apple picking that
you can't pick was friends but you can
pick your apples lisa
that is good clean fun oh i don't know
you were you were
you were sticking your head in a well in
a board god knows where that board has
been
kt rescue me from wherever i am right
now
i'm off in a deep world and i can't get
out of it yeah well it's like being at
the bottom of the bottle
look how dare they how dare the new york
times the virtuous new york times
go after people who are fat and people
who are depressed
right is that not discrimination yes it
is not that the most horrible form of
discrimination
because it's discriminating against how
somebody looks yep
the other thing that is amazing is the
new york times
they've got somebody writing about this
stuff have they looked at their own
bottom line lately do you know the only
part of the new york times that actually
is getting
new members to join up new subscriptions
is the recipe section
that's hilarious also if you want to be
hot like look hot you actually really
need uglier friends
thank you thank you thank you finally we
come to it
you need exclusively fat
you look like a million bucks let's go
they know where the best food is you
look better than them you cheer them up
you're a role model
this is why i hang around you because i
look like a sharp dresser
i will be the yin to your yang i
remember the first time i
my i've met you and she's it's so nice
that you take the the homeless people
out for
but isn't like most of the country fat
and depressed
that's why nobody's reading the new york
times i think that um i think that
we have shifted the bmi definition so
that everybody
is obese like by definition and we
everybody
almost everybody qualifies for a mental
issue because of whatever
drug you might be on i thought i mean i
think that
that it's wise to pick your you don't
want to have
bad influences in your life but she
picked
she that is what she said was a very har
very bad thing to say that like oh
just if somebody's depressed get them
out of no you want somebody
depressed people can be positive to your
life it's people that are a
negative drain on you that are bad
vampires
suck out all of you exactly all right
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else